oh who could forget that magic moment
maybe it's John Cena that was when he um
pop the question to Nikki Bella and of
course she said yes that was a year ago
this month yeah they were so happy that
it was so romantic but there have been a
lot of problems ever so long and now the
wedding is officially off last night
Nikki released this breakup statement
she and John are splitting after six
years together quote while this decision
was a difficult one we continue to have
a great deal of love and respect for one
another the first inkling that there was
something wrong in their relationship
came in February when John co-hosted on
today and was asked about this promo
from total Bella's so you really want to
call this off that was an extreme low
and you have two choices you either jump
ship didn't start a new relationship or
move forward and try to work through it
in late March John admitted to et they
went through a rough patch but there may
5th wedding was still on I love her I
don't want to live without her so I'd
rather a hard conversation and ice get
through it as a couple then not talk
about it and let her go after John's
stunning proposal Nikki showed us her
four and a half carat engagement ring
and we went wedding-dress shopping I
feel like I'm very drawn towards lace I
don't want anything like too big and I'm
so bad with it all last season Nikki
competed on Dancing with the Stars with
John cheering her on and less than two
weeks ago at the premiere of his film
blockers the couple told me they were
looking towards spending their post
wedding summer together
is there a vacation maybe it might be a
honeymoon
I hope there's a few vacation last night
seemingly commenting on the surprise let
John posted this Simpsons name worst day
ever
whatever went wrong with her romance
Tron did admit to et it was tough to be
in the public eye it's a weird thing
that our relationship is public for the
world to know but would it you know
would have good takeaway for everyone at
home like relationships of time
[Music]